Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hey, Magenta. Wie soll ich denn mit Linus jetzt die Sendung initiieren?
Es tut mir leid. Ich kann dir bei deiner Linux-Installation leider nicht helfen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 547 vom 25.
Februar 2026 und ist es nicht schön,
wenn man jetzt den Chatbot direkt im Podcast hat und alle Fragen,
die wir so haben, einfach so zwischendurch abfragen können und dann kriegt man
die Antworten und man muss überhaupt nichts mehr wissen, wenn man irgendwie
einen Podcast machen will.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass ich dann gar nicht weiß, wenn ich nicht podcaste,
wie ich noch so schöne dritte Personen dabei habe.
Du meinst, wenn du nicht podcastest, dann fehlt dir das?
Ich glaube, das ist das, was die sich bei der Telekom irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht, ob die darüber nachgedacht haben.
Aber,
Ich habe überhaupt nicht den Eindruck, dass die darüber über irgendwas nachgedacht haben.
Das ist wirklich, also das ist eine faszinierende Idee, wo man sich echt fragt,
hat da keiner je, niemals, also habt ihr alle,
das ist so ein bisschen wie bei der elektronischen Patientenakte,
mit der unverschlüsselten elektronischen Patientenakte ohne Passwort,
ohne zweiten Faktor, ohne alles.
Wo man sich denkt.
So hat nicht, was, wie habt ihr das hingekriegt, dass niemand im Raum,
gesagt hat, warte mal,
meint er nicht, das musst du erst mal hinkriegen.
Also so eine Kultur musst du erst mal aufbauen. Das ist ein beachtliches Werk.
Ist das nicht Standard? Ich meine, immer wenn so der aktuelle Hypetrain durch
den Sitzungsraum durchfährt.
Ich sehe richtig förmlich diese Vorstandsrunde bei der Telekom,
wo dann einer sagt, ja, also mit dieser KI, da müssen wir jetzt unbedingt was machen.
Da reden ja alle drüber. Ja, was denn?
Am Telefon.
Was können wir denn da machen? Jetzt haben doch alle diese Chatbots in den Webseiten.
Das bauen wir dann einfach ins Telefon ein. Ja, geil.
Und schon reden sie wieder davon, da die Zukunft zu gestalten und irgendwie,
Also was ist passiert? Also Vorstandsmitglied Abdul Modizir kündigt an,
dass die Telekom bald ein Chatbot direkt in die Telefonate einklingt.
Also man telefoniert jetzt. Wir beide reden so. Ja, wie machen wir jetzt die
nächste Sendung, Linus?
Hört eine KI mit und wartet auf ihren Einsatz.
Sag mal, genau. Ja, aber Linus, ich bitte dich. Das ist natürlich,
also die hört ja nicht mit.
Nee, nee. Die hört ja nicht mit, sondern die hört ja erst mit,
wenn du Hey Magenta sagst.
Dann schaltet dein Telefon frei.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man auf so eine Idee kommt.
Es ist einfach so eine, ja, und dann sagt er, unser KI-Assistent agiert als
vertrauensvoller Partner für alle Kunden.
Ja, aber also guck mal, also mal ganz ernsthaft, Tim. Wenn du,
also angenommen, du hast ein Telefonat, also das passiert ja schon selten genug.
Also die einzige Funktion, die ich mir vorstellen könnte, die ich wirklich gebrauchen
könnte, jetzt merke ich so der Use Case, hey Magenta,
lenkt den Callcenter Scamcaller längere Zeit noch weiter ab.
Das wäre so das wäre so eine halt den hin,
weißt du so das wäre eine Funktionalität wo ich sagen würde okay,
Da könnte ich so ein Ding gebrauchen. Aber die wollen ja etwas,
die bilden sich ja ein, sie würden etwas bauen, was irgendjemandem behilflich ist.
Die Frage ist, wobei denn? Beim Telefonieren oder was?
Also so, Telefon klingelt. Hallo, Telefonmann. So, oder?
Und dann? Dann sagst du, ja, okay, fassen wir mal das Gespräch zusammen.
Also welche, um Himmels Willen, welchen Use Case.
Du fragst dann einfach so Sachen, die man wissen muss. Wie viele Einwohner hat Wanne Eickel?
Kennst du das nicht?
Weiß man.
Ja, weiß man. Ja, sag mal.
Warte, ich hab's jetzt nicht schnell genug gegugelt.
Moment, mein Schöp.
Ja, so. Oder wie viele weibliche Bürgermeister hatte Wanne Eickel bisher? So war's.
So, Wanne-Eickel ist gar keine eigene Stadt mehr, sondern Teil von Herne.
Jetzt willst du dich doch nur rausreden. Er ist jetzt Herne-Wanne.
Ja klar.
Was denn, hat jetzt der Chatbot gesagt oder was? Warum hast du Wanne-Eickel?
Das ist Fakt. Das gesamte Stadtgebiet Herne hat irgendwie so irgendwie 160, 175.000, 160.000.
Naja.
Herne-Wanne hat 34.500. So.
Nenne mir einen Use Case. Dann können wir ja darüber reden, ob wir jetzt sagen,
okay, wir geben das Fernmeldegeheimnis auf.
Wenn wir einen vernünftigen Use Case finden, dann bin ich ja bereit,
jedes Grundrecht in den Wind zu schießen, wenn es mein Leben ein bisschen einfacher macht.
Stell dir mal vor, du sagst, das Problem ist ja,
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was das Problem ist. Aber auf jeden Fall wirst du,
also was mache ich denn, wenn ich jetzt den Chatbot, wenn ich den nachher bedienen will?
Wenn ich sage, fass mal nochmal zusammen, was Oma letzten Sonntag am Telefon alles erzählt hat.
Also kann ich dir leider nicht helfen. Also ist der in jedem Gespräch?
Damit geht es ja schon mal los.
Also um mir irgendeinen Nutzen zu bringen, müsste der ja auch noch State haben.
Dann stell dir mal vor, dann merkt er sich einfach alle deine Telefonate.
Was halt richtig, also ich meine, das Ding ist einfach nur ein absoluter Überwachungsalbtraum,
so einen kleinen Stasi-Magenta, der so alle dein Memory,
hey Magenta, was habe ich letzte Woche noch mal mit meiner Oma besprochen.
Du sagst das aber im falschen Telefonat mit der anderen Oma.
Dann sagt er, ihr habt die halbe Stunde über die andere Oma gelästert oder so.
Übrigens, ich sage die ganze Zeit Oma, weil das die einzigen Menschen sind,
mit denen man über normale, unverschlüsselte Telefonie telefoniert.
Natürlich, man würde ja längst auf irgendein paketvermitteltes,
verschlüsseltes System zurückgreifen, damit man nicht irgendeinen KI-Agenten mit im Telefon hat.
Vor allem KI-Agent im Telefon, das klingt nun wirklich nicht nach meinem Freund.
Also das ist ja auf zwei Ebenen ist das ja gleich so ein richtiger Doppelfail.
Also allein schon die Ankündigung jetzt reicht ja.
Also sie müssen jetzt auch nichts machen und das ist jetzt eigentlich schon alles im Arsch.
Erstens, diese Vorstellung davon,
Dass sie also wirklich eine Technologie einbauen wollen, die alles...
Und die einfach so stumm auf Aktivierung lauscht und sich sozusagen jetzt ab
morgen niemand mehr sicher sein kann, ob nicht die ganze Zeit sozusagen zugehört wird.
Und das zweite ist, dass sie damit natürlich auch nochmal schön dokumentieren,
wie unsicher unsere normale Telefonie per se eigentlich ist.
Weil ja sozusagen der Betreiber in der Lage ist, jederzeit da sich einfach mal
in diesen Kanal einzuschalten.
So nach dem Motto, Sicherheit ist bei uns einfach mal generell erstmal nicht gegeben.
Und das ist so ein fucking Eigentor, was sie dann auch noch so auf ihrer eigenen
Marke, ja wohlgemerkt, wir erinnern uns, letzte Sendung, ja, im besten Netz.
Netz, das beste Netz.
Was wir haben.
Bisher so hatten. Das machen wir jetzt auch gleich kaputt.
Ich kann nur hoffen, dass sie das Ding bis Barcelona schon wieder eingestampft haben, diesen Plan.
Wer auch immer da in dem Vorstand für so eine Idee zuständig ist,
dass der es vielleicht dann doch mal mit Holz probieren sollte.
Aber das zeigt einfach diese,
Halbfixierung mit wir müssen jetzt auch irgendwas mit KI machen.
Und dann so die Antwort ist so, ja, aber wir haben doch eigentlich gar keine Ahnung von KI.
Ich meine, es ist ja noch nicht mal so, dass wir uns jetzt auch nur im Entferntesten
vorstellen können, dass jetzt die Telekom anfängt, für die Kapazität aller ihrer
Telefonate eigene Datencenter aufzubauen und dann irgendwie am Ende vielleicht
sogar noch eine eigene AI trainiert.
Das ist doch vollkommener Quatsch.
Die werden sich irgendwie bei OpenAI einklinken und fertig.
Ja, ja.
Genau. Und das ist halt auch noch der, ja, aber wir sind es endlich leid,
immer nur die Pipes zu sein.
Deswegen peipen wir jetzt alle eure Telefonate zur Omae ein.
Genau. Und übrigens, wir sind auch voll souverän.
Ja.
Du kannst gar nicht, also das ist so ein Fraktal von Blöden, von Blödheit.
Das ist wirklich so schreit.
Kannst du gar nicht. Da brauchst du auch ein LLM für, um das irgendwie zu, also ja.
Was machen wir mit denen?
Und nochmal, was ich nicht verstehe ist,
kannst du dir irgendwie so eine User Journey vorstellen?
Also kannst du irgendwie, wenn die dann so sagen, ja hier, hier haben wir eine
Persona, Jetzt lassen wir uns überlegen, was will die?
Die will telefonieren. Hm, so.
Und jetzt hat sie aber einen plötzlichen Bedarf am Telefon.
Welcher Form? Welcher Form? Also nenne mir, also abgesehen von, dass das ein totaler,
also wirklich unglaublichen Vertrauensschaden anrichtet an dem eigenen Telefonnetz
und so weiter. Aber mal angenommen.
Es könnte ja sein, dass es irgendwie einen unglaublichen Use Case gibt,
wo alle sagen, ne pass auf, die
wissen eh, das Netz ist abhörbar und die wissen eh, das ist alles Käse.
Aber die wollen das, die brauchen, die sind am Telefon und wollen unbedingt
jetzt was kaufen und die brauchen eine KI, die das für sie macht.
Dafür unterbrechen sie ihr Gespräch.
Sie haben ja jemanden angerufen und gesagt, nein, nein, nein.
Ich brauche im Gespräch jemanden mehr, der mir assistiert.
Okay, kann ja sein. Der sagt immer nochmal, pass mal auf, der schreit so ein,
der sagt so, ey, ruhig bleiben.
Hey, ich wollte, könnte ja auch sein, so ein Therapeuten, so ein Paartherapeuten.
Hey, Magenta, Paartherapeuten.
Nein. Ist das den anderen auch mal ausreden?
Ja, aber, also du, da hat der schon einen Punkt. Da musst du jetzt noch drauf
eingehen. Könnt ihr sein, so ein Moderator.
Aber nichts davon kann ich mir vorstellen,
dass man damit klarkommt, weil du ja diesen einen Audiokanal hast,
ich nicht weiß, wer am anderen Ende spricht, weil du keine Videotelefonie hast,
und wenn da jetzt noch einer mitmacht, sobald du mit drei Leuten telefonierst,
ist es immer so, äh, warte, nee, nee, sag du jetzt.
Und Magenta dann immer so, ich, nein, Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass irgendetwas damit, also nur wenn du nur einen Werbespot machen musst,
so jetzt im Telekom-Netz, KI,
welchen Werbespot machst du, wo dann am Ende machst du, du, du, du, du, du, du,
Und alle so, boah geil, so will ich auch telefonieren. Ich will auch telefonieren,
wo einer dazwischen plappert.
Und dann ist das Telefonat vorbei und der Assistent ist weg.
Und genau dann brauche ich ihn ja. Nämlich, was hat der gerade nochmal gesagt?
Scheiße, ich wollte mir doch, ich wollte doch jetzt irgendwas machen. Waren drei Sachen.
Das soll ja angeblich nicht gehen. Aber ich glaube, also ich habe auch schon
so den Case, warum sie das auch innerhalb kürzester Zeit wieder einstellen müssen.
Und zwar wegen Geld.
Dann werden die niemals ausrollen.
Naja, das Ding ist ja, wenn du jetzt, also was sie ja nicht tun können, ist dafür Geld nehmen.
Also wenn sie jetzt ankündigen, alle eure Telefonate kosten jetzt mehr,
weil KI. Dann sagen alle, habt ihr sie noch alle.
Ja, klar.
Also ist es kostenlos. Sie können aber jetzt Sie.
Nehmen Geld dafür, das wieder abzuschalten.
Ja, aber sie können jetzt auch nicht sagen, Ja, nee, die ersten zehn Fragen
sind kostenlos und danach kostet es Geld,
weil dann rennen natürlich dann Leute wieder in irgendwelche Fallen rein,
wie mit den 190er-Nummern.
Das wird auch aufgerusogen, also müssen sie es kostenlos machen.
Damit es aber sinnvoll ist, müssen sie eigentlich so ein OpenAI freischalten.
Das wiederum bedeutet, du kannst halt einfach deinen Computer einmal sozusagen
sich selber anrufen lassen und dann hast du einen kostenlosen Chatbot und kannst
OpenAI sozusagen durch deine Mobilfunkleitung hindurch einfach kostenlos benutzen und dann wird die AI,
die Telekom so viel Geld kosten,
dass sie das auch wieder abschalten müssen.
Also es ist einfach, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ist mit diesen Leuten los
und vor allem, was war nochmal kurz die Qualifizierung für so einen Vorstandsposten?
Also, ja.
Also ich glaube, dass du halt dann sagst so…,
Also was vielleicht noch ganz schön wäre, wäre so, ja, ich habe eine Anfrage
an dich und bitte beantworte mir die mit in V90, dass es schneller ist, weißt du?
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was wir da machen.
Sprich Mode mit mir.
Ja, klar.
Ach Mann, ey, Deutschland. Das ist einfach, ich meine, schöner hätte man es
jetzt nicht dokumentieren können, dass hier einfach mal so die ganze Kreativität,
was so Technologie betrifft und Technologieführerschaft, einfach ein einziges,
hinterherrennen.
Naja, man muss, also vielleicht war es auch einfach nur eins,
die haben sich gesagt, lass uns irgendwas in die Nachrichten bringen mit KI.
Hauptsache unser Aktienkurs geht auch nicht irgendwie 20% runter,
nur weil Anthropic mal wieder geblockt hat.
Ja, natürlich ist das der einzige Grund. Also deswegen sage ich ja,
das ist so eine Vorstandsitzung, wir müssen jetzt irgendwas mit KI machen,
nicht weil sie der Meinung sind, dass das jetzt unbedingt ein Service ist,
den alle brauchen oder alle Telekom-Kunden rufen schon die ganze Zeit beim Support an und sagen,
ja wieso kann ich denn hier meinen Chatbot nicht aufrufen in meinem Telefon.
Das ist ja das, was ich schon immer gebraucht habe.
Und es findet ja alles nicht statt, sondern es geht nur darum,
so ein Buzzword zu besetzen, dann auf so einer Posing-Veranstaltung wie diesem
Mobile World Congress in Barcelona, der so die CeBIT abgelöst hat,
da irgendwie einen dicken Max zu machen.
Und ich meine, du warst ja wahrscheinlich schon mal da auf dieser MWC in Barcelona.
Es ist halt so, wie du es dir vorstellst, also Hallen voll.
Deswegen war ich auch nicht da.
Ja, es ist alles ganz furchtbar. Und dann steht halt überall jetzt auch mit KI.
In irgendeiner Form. Und jeder hat irgendein KI-Produkt und wenn du fragst,
warum, dann sagen sie ja, wegen, weiß ich auch nicht.
Wir müssen, wir müssen.
Der Aktienkurs. Genau so. Der Aktienkurs.
Ja, also, und das ist ja, ich halte da regelmäßig, führe ich darüber Gespräche
und halte darüber Vorträge.
Ich meine, ja, Unternehmen müssen jetzt was mit KI machen.
Und es ist auch so, dass sich viele Geschäftsmodelle auf dem Prüfstand befinden
und da viel disruptiert wird und so.
Aber was dann halt richtig tragisch ist, ist, wenn sie damit scheiße machen.
Das hat ja auch Opportunitätskosten und sei es nur das Geld.
Und deswegen finde ich das so...
Ja, also bemitleidenswert.
Also ich meine, okay, dass AI disruptiv ist in bestimmten Bereichen,
haben wir hier auch alle schon ausführlich diskutiert, es steht ja vollkommen außer Frage.
Genau, und dann musst du halt in den Bereichen, wo es disruptiv ist,
musst du jetzt halt zusehen, dass du da, dass du diese Einsätze,
wo es sinnvoll ist, bei dir findest und auch nutzt, weil sonst macht es jemand anders.
Ja, aber doch nicht im Mobilfunk.
Aber das Entscheidende ist natürlich die sinnvollen, ja genau,
das Entscheidende ist die sinnvollen zu finden.
Ja, das ist Unsinn.
Und das ist halt keiner. Hier hätten wir ein Beispiel für einen nicht so sinnvollen.
Und das ist sehr traurig.
Jetzt versuch mal ein Beispiel für einen sinnvollen.
Aus der Perspektive der Telekom? Sollen wir da mal ein Businessmodell entwickeln?
Tatsächlich hat die Telekom,
also tatsächlich sind die an dem Thema schon relativ früh dran gewesen,
so und haben sie irgendwie Prototypen vorgestellt von dem,
ja quasi, also ich sag jetzt nicht, dass es gut ist oder das App-lose Handy,
das einfach Dinge macht, ne?
Ja, aber sie wollen immer in Bereiche vorstoßen, die einfach nicht ihr Bier sind.
Das ist ja dieser alte feuchte Traum von den Mobilfunkbetreibern,
was sie nicht alles in den letzten Jahren schon probiert haben.
Werbung in Webseiten einblenden, ja, einfach da auch wieder so eine Mende, eine Mende,
dann halt irgendwie diese ganzen zugangsbeschränkten Dienste,
so nach dem Motto, ja, hier für den Normaltarif kannst du Facebook und Twitter
machen und wenn du ein richtiges Internet haben willst, musst du extra bezahlen.
Also die ganze Zeit wollen sie in irgendeiner Form an die Services ran und die
Leute melken und quasi einen Mehrwert erfinden, der eigentlich im Wesentlichen
immer nur bedeutet, dass der Default einfach schlechter ist.
Und das ist halt einfach nicht geil. Vor allem nicht, wenn man irgendwie jetzt
damit wirbt, man hätte ja nun das beste Netz.
Gut, klar, sie haben ja in Deutschland immer noch so ein bisschen Standortvorteile
und das ist, sagen wir mal,
das einzige oder einer der wenigen Argumente für diese Behauptung,
dass sie jetzt ein besseres Netz seien als andere Netze.
Wenn ich mir so die anderen Netze so anschaue, sie haben auch Schwierigkeiten
zu behaupten, dass sie jetzt wiederum das beste Netz seien, aber nur weil man
das beste Netz ist, heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass man ein gutes Netz hat.
Und darauf könnten sie sich ja eigentlich mal konzentrieren und wir haben ja
ihre ganzen Verfehlungen im Bereich Glasfaser und Ausbaupolitik und so weiter
und Service schon ausreichend beklagt und ich finde das sind einfach Dinge,
auf die man sich konzentriert.
Aber nein, jetzt muss irgendwie wieder dem Hype-Train irgendwie hinterher gerannt
werden, der eigentlich schon längst aus dem Bahnhof ist und auch nicht dahin
fährt, wo die hin müssen und geben jetzt sinnlos Geld aus für Quatsch,
den sie wahrscheinlich schon einstellen müssen, bevor sie das überhaupt offiziell
announced haben, weil der Aufschrei wird einfach groß sein.
Also wurde bei uns schon verlacht, bevor sie es auf die Messe getragen haben.
Was ich dann noch interessant finde, ist, dann sagen sie, ja,
das richtet sich an den Markt, wo die Leute Tastenhandys haben.
Und sagen sie, guck mal hier, wir bringen I for one welcome out AI overlords,
wir bringen die AI aufs Wählscheibentelefon. und auch das ist natürlich total,
das war auch eine richtige Disruption, aber jetzt überlege ich mal bitte was
ist das denn für ein Markt,
ich meine das Marktsegment wo entweder kein also wirklich kein Geld ist da bringst
du jetzt KI hin geil, voll dank da wird OBI dir danken, dass du denen das.
Kostenlos zur Verfügung stellst und oder Aufruhr im Altersheim sag ich dir Ja.
Oder genau, oder es ist halt im Alter sein, wo die Leute aus guten Gründen sagen,
ich hätte gerne Telefon mit Tasten, so, und wenn ich auf die 1 drücke,
kriege ich meinen Enkel,
und wenn ich auf die 2 drücke meine Tochter, und wenn ich auf die 3 drücke,
den Bestatter, so, aber das ist irgendwie so, ich verstehe eigentlich.
Jetzt kannst du aber auch sagen, kannst du auf die 9 drücken,
und dann kriegst du halt den erfundenen Enkel, der sozusagen,
so Enkel trägt mal andersrum, weißt du, da wird dann einfach,
der Enkel wird dann einfach erfunden.
So, das wäre natürlich ein Feature, wo ich sagen würde, okay,
da können wir drüber reden, wenn ich jetzt hier von der Telekom irgendwie, wenn die sagen,
wir machen eine AI, die antwortet, die klärt Dinge für dich,
da könnte man drüber reden, aber die sind genau die einen, die es mir nicht
anbieten können, weil die damit natürlich,
ich nicht mehr sagen würde, ich habe hier ein vertrauenswürdiges Netz.
Und vor allem, wenn sie das Produkt telefonen.
Das ist alles.
Jetzt sind wir schon irgendwie so.
Linus, warum müssen wir immer so eine Scheiße besprechen? Das ist doch einfach.
Ich meine, Leute, wirklich, kommt doch mal klar. Ach Gott.
Ich fasse es nicht. Lass euch doch mal was einfallen.
Ich will das jetzt haben. Wenn ich das nicht kriege, dann verklage ich die,
weil ich habe das in der Zeitung gelesen und die haben mich Oh Mann.
Ey Naja, okay, vielleicht sollte ich auch Hey Meta-Ebene einführen Podcast On Demand,
Kommen wir mal zu ernsten Themen Ernsten Themen Weil.
Was ja also, wenn es dann Hey Magenta gibt, ja, dann muss ja eine Sache,
ist ja wohl klar, nicht für Jugendliche.
Da müsste sofort eine Altersbeschränkung dran.
Nach oben oder nach unten?
Nach unten, damit die Jugendlichen ihre Oma nicht damit verarschen.
Oder ist die Oma sich nicht selbst verarschen. Naja, gut, also wir wollen mal
ein paar Kommentare vorlesen aus der letzten Sendung, wie wir das so oft machen
und das sind ein paar mehr und ein bisschen länger.
Und zwar drehen die sich jetzt eigentlich nahezu alle um das Thema Social Media
Verbot und ich wollte das einfach mal machen, um nochmal so ein paar andere
Perspektiven, die da aufgelaufen sind. Als meine.
Oder auch meine. Also es sind ja alle möglichen Perspektiven.
Ja, um das einfach mal so ein bisschen,
Abzurunden damit vielleicht auch die ganze Diskussion.
Ich fange an mit Flo. Ich gehe mit in der Argumentation von Linus,
dass die Probleme von Tabak, Alkohol und Glücksspiel im Erwachsenenalter gesellschaftlich
nicht durch ein Verbot gelöst werden.
Allerdings sehe ich das Hauptargument der Befürworterin einer Altersbeschränkung
bei Social Media in der weitaus anfälligeren Entwicklung des Kindes.
Hier kann ein Verbot durchaus wirken, genauso wie es bei Alkohol und Tabak im
Kindesalter bereits selbstverständlich praktiziert wird.
Nicht weil Verbote grundsätzlich das gesellschaftliche Problem lösen,
sondern weil Kinder in ihrem biologischen, soziologischen und psychologischen
Entwicklungskontext einen besonderen Schutz brauchen.
Dem schließt sich auch Martino an und sagt exakt das.
Die Altersgrenzen für Alkohol, Tabak und Glücksspiel basieren auf der Erkenntnis,
dass der körperliche Schaden für Kinder und Jugendliche besonders groß ist,
die Anfälligkeit für Süchte höher ist und zudem die Fähigkeit,
einen problematischen Umgang bei sich selbst zu erkennen und gegenzusteuern,
noch nicht so ausgeprägt ist wie bei Erwachsenen.
Alles natürlich mit statistischen Schwankungen, die Ausnahmen in beide Richtungen
erzeugen. Deshalb belegen wir Alkohol, Tabak und Glücksspiel mit Altersgrenzen
nicht, weil es alle Menschen schützt und alle Probleme verhindert.
Es ist eine Abwägung zwischen dem Schutz der Schwächsten und der Freiheit aller,
diese Dinge trotzdem zu tun.
Diese Argumente werden nun auf Social Media übertragen. Die alte Hippe fügt
folgende Gedanken hinzu.
Was für mich machbar wäre, ist eine gezielte Regulierung der Plattformen,
die alle Userinnen betrifft.
Diese Regulierung muss beinhalten, dass eine Moderation eingeführt wird,
die auch ihren Namen verdient.
Inhalte dürfen sich nicht lediglich nach der Strafbarkeit richten,
sondern es müssen grundlegende Dinge wie Mobbing, menschenfeindliche Propaganda usw.
Verboten werden. Die Regulierung könnte dann wie folgt durchgesetzt werden.
Erstens Mahnung, zweitens Geldstrafe, drittens höhere Geldstrafe,
viertens Sperrung der gesamten Plattform im Land, fünftens alles davon muss
zügig durchgeführt werden, keine monatelange Wartezeit.
Ja, eine Sperrung kann man umgeben, aber das machen gefühlt nur die Hörerinnen
von Lochblut-Netzpolitik, deshalb ist das eine machbare Option.
Fazit, man kann die Plattform regulieren, braucht kein Verbot von Social Media,
das ausschließlich Kinder und Jugendliche unter dem Vorwand des Schutzes benachteiligt.
Ja, ähm,
Dann Phil. Ich wollte bei der Diskussion zu Social Media darauf hinweisen,
dass die Problemdiagnose hier noch ziemlich schwammig ist.
Klar bauen die Unternehmen ihre Seiten, um Nutzungszeiten zu maximieren und
Kinder sind da leicht verführbar.
Den umfassenderen Behauptungen, Social Media hätte verheerende Effekte auf Kinder,
hängt aber nach meinem Empfinden etwas der Geschmack einer Moral Panic an.
Es ist empirisch überhaupt nicht klar, ob Social Media bzw.
Die mentale Gesundheit von Kindern schädigt. Und selbst die Studien,
die finden, dass es das tut, finden nur relativ kleine Effekte.
In der Diskussion, nicht unbedingt bei euch, klingt es aber manchmal so,
als wäre das hier eindeutig der Untergang des Abendlandes und als würden flächendeckend
die mentale Gesundheit von Kindern ruiniert.
Das ist aber, wie gesagt, gar nicht klar und war so ähnlich sicher auch die
Befürchtung der alten Menschen, als Radio und Fernsehen aufkam.
Die Forderung nach einem Verbot klingt für mich eher nach klassischem The Kids
These Days Gerede und der Absicht beim alten Wahlvolk einfache Punkte zu holen,
ohne Rücksicht darauf, was Kindern nun wirklich helfen würde.
Das war einmal noch. Andreas fügt folgendes hinzu.
Also ich muss ja jetzt wirklich mal was zu sagen bezüglich möglicher Altersbegrenzung
oder Einschränkung von Social Media Plattformen für Kinder. Natürlich ist das,
was Linus sagt, richtig.
Natürlich müssten die Plattformen dazu gezwungen werden, diese ganzen süchtig
machenden Algorithmen und so weiter nicht mehr anwenden zu dürfen.
Natürlich muss es knallharte Regelungen dafür geben zum Schutz aller.
So viel in der Theorie. Aber selbst wenn es sie teilweise gibt,
man kommt mit ihnen nicht richtig durch.
Du könntest jetzt auch den Tabak verbieten und trotzdem würde es Leute geben,
die illegal Tabak irgendwie beschaffen, denen dann Kinder ohne Altersbegrenzung auch rauchen dürften.
Weil die Konzerne dürfen ihn
ja nicht mehr herstellen. Was jetzt vom Balkon kommt, ist ja dann okay.
Nein, so funktioniert das Leben leider nicht. Nur durch Regeln,
eben auch Altersregeln.
Eben auch als Jugendschutz bekannt, funktioniert manches so, wie es sein sollte.
Gilt für brutale Filme, gilt für Pornografie, gilt für gewisse Lebensmittel,
für Getränke oder sonst was.
Ohne zu bestimmen, für welche Altersgruppen etwas geeignet ist,
würde es in jeder Hinsicht drunter und drüber gehen.
Mir ist es ein Rätsel, warum davon das Internet ausgenommen sein sollte.
Warum sollten davon Social-Media-Plattformen ausgenommen sein?
Zumindest was wir jetzt gerade im Moment erleben, führt ja zu folgender Erkenntnis auch bei mir.
Bis vor ein paar Jahren wäre ich auch gegen eine Altersbegrenzung gewesen,
aber die Realität zeigt mir etwas anderes.
Ich habe selber noch schulpflichtige Kinder und kann euch nur sagen,
da gibt es einen Großteil in jener Schulklasse, die ganz klar geschützt werden müsste.
Die Folgen sind schon auf 20 Meter Entfernung offensichtlich.
Da sind schon so viele Schicksale in den Brunnen gefallen, dass es ein Schaden,
der diese Leute ein Leben lang verfolgen wird.
Hätte es ein altersbegrenzendes Verbot gegeben, wären sicherlich einige von
den Kindern ohne diese Schäden davon gekommen.
Welche Schäden sind das genau?
Die Schäden sind so dermaßen groß, dass manche von denen noch nicht mal mehr
in der Lage sind, 15 Minuten einem Unterricht zu folgen.
Konzentrationsfähigkeit leicht. War ich noch nie. Ja, und damit meine ich nicht
die langweiligen Unterricht, den wir auch von früher kennen und dem wir auch
nicht 15 Minuten lang gefolgt sind.
Wenn wir als Gesellschaft warten, bis wir die Plattformen so weit haben,
dass sie eventuell irgendwann mal ihr Angebot so dermaßen einbremsen müssen,
dass diese Gefahren vielleicht geringer werden, bis dahin ist unsere Gesellschaft schon kaputt.
Viele Eltern können das überhaupt nicht abschätzen. Das ist so eine brutale Gefahr.
Das wäre das Gleiche, als wenn der Alkohol aus allen Ecken der Wohnung quellen
würde und direkt in den Mund läuft.
Dieses Social Media ist so nah, das ist einfach so präsent.
In jedem Moment, wo man sein Smartphone in die Hand nimmt, Und da ist die aktive
Aktion, um zum Beispiel eine Dose Bier zu kaufen, da ging fast ein Marathonlauf.
Nein, unsere Kinder müssen davor mit einem Verbot geschützt werden.
Zusätzlich muss natürlich auch an die Älteren gedacht werden.
Wie Linus sagt, da muss natürlich die Plattform reguliert werden.
Aber ich sehe da in den nächsten Jahren kaum eine Möglichkeit,
die Plattform so unter Kontrolle zu kriegen.
Da müssen wir eben unser Europa unter Kontrolle kriegen und unsere Kinder dort aktiv schützen.
Auch wenn das vielleicht graue Männer sind, die das fordern oder dass das so
scheint, frag mal junge Lehrer an den Schulen, frag mal die Vertrauenslehrer
und die Schulpsychologen, was da los ist.
Das sind Leute, die sind 30 bis 40 Jahre alt und die müssen zerstörte Kindheitsgemüter
feststellen und das täglich.
Einen habe ich noch von nur so ein Gedanke.
Ein Verbot von sozialen Medien greift meiner Ansicht nach zu kurz,
denn es löst nicht das eigentliche Problem.
Die entscheidende Fähigkeit, sowohl im Umgang mit sozialen Medien als auch mit
elektronischen Geräten allgemein, ist die Kontrolle der eigenen Impulse.
Wann, wo, warum und wie lange nutze ich das Gerät?
Schon lange vor der algorithmischen Verführung durch personalisierte Inhalte
müssen Menschen gelernt haben, ihr eigenes Verhalten zu steuern.
Das Selbst-Selbst-Reflektionen voraus, einen anstrengenden Prozess,
der uns Menschen nicht leicht fällt.
Ist es für Erwachsene schon schwierig, so sind Kinder unter 14 Jahren in der
Regel noch nicht in der Lage, ihr Verhalten bewusst zu hinterfragen.
Es ist faszinierend zu sehen, wie sich ihre Wahrnehmung ab diesem Alter anfängt zu verändern.
Doch bis sie ihr Handeln wirklich kontrollieren können, dauert es noch lange.
Was sie jedoch sofort lernen, und zwar mit dem ersten Kontakt,
ist, digitale Geräte sind spannender als die reale Welt.
Dieser Wahrnehmung sind sie oft mit der Begründung, sie dürften den Anschluss
nicht verpassen, schutzlos ausgeliefert.
Da Mensch immer lernt, also nicht lernen kann, verstärkt die frühe Nutzung das
falsche Verhalten, das später mühsam wieder korrigiert werden muss.
Solange wir ihnen also nicht beibringen, ihre Impulse zu steuern,
bleibt ein Verbot nur noch ein verzweifelter Versuch, ein Problem zu lösen,
das wir noch nicht richtig verstanden haben.
Leider kann das Problem durch die Eltern allein nicht gelöst werden.
Der Gruppendruck und die soziale Ausgrenzung bei Kindern, die nicht dabei sind,
ist enorm, sodass hier eine demokratische Regelung notwendig ist,
um einheitliche Bedingungen zu schaffen.
Darüber hinaus sollten die Schulen das Erlernen der mentalen Fähigkeiten pädagogisch
begleiten, wegen mir auch anstatt des schlecht ausgestatteten Informatikunterrichts.
Das war jetzt mal so eine Packung von verschiedenen Kommentaren.
Es gab noch mehr, aber ich würde mal sagen, das deckt das Spektrum der Antworten,
die wir jetzt dazu erhalten haben, ganz gut ab.
Also verbieten wir es doch jetzt?
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass die Kommentare alle in eine Richtung weisen,
aber man sieht hier, glaube ich, ganz gut, dass es auch sehr unterschiedliche
Einschätzungen und Befürchtungen gibt.
Einerseits, andererseits, dass also, glaube ich, auch auf jeden Fall so ein
Konsens da ist, dass man sich auf jeden Fall...
Vor allem auf die Regulierung der Plattformen konzentrieren sollte.
Also das ist mindestens die mittel- und langfristige Lösung hier,
also die ich jetzt auch aus dem Feedback rauslese und die auch generell ja unterstützen
kann, weil wir im Wesentlichen ja diese algorithmische Bespielung.
Dauerbespielung, dass das eben vor allem das Problem ist.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch so ein paar andere süchtig machende Effekte,
so dieses permanente schnelle Nachliefern, dieser TikTok-Effekt,
das ist, und bei Instagram ist es ja nicht viel besser und YouTube hat ja auch
solche Funktionen, also alle liefern das ja im Prinzip nach, swipe, swipe, swipe,
zack, zack, zack, zack, ein Ding nach dem anderen und abgesehen davon.
Dass halt hier vor allem beklagt wird, Das ist sozusagen ein bisschen diese
Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie und damit auch so die Kommunikation untereinander einfängt.
Und ich denke, das hat jeder auch schon mal miterlebt, der das ein bisschen
mit Kindern begleitet hat.
Nicht nur mit Kindern, aber vor allem eben auch mit Kindern.
Und das ist nochmal so ein anderer Aspekt.
Offen ist natürlich jetzt, inwiefern ein Verbot hilft.
Stimmt sicherlich, also keiner von uns geht davon aus, dass jetzt sozusagen
ein Verbot sich technisch uneingeschränkt umsetzen lässt.
Andererseits ist es halt schon so, dass wir es hier mit einem Phänomen zu tun haben,
was offensichtlich bei Kids einfach auch wirklich eine krasse Wirkung hat und
das ist ja nicht nur dieses Algorithmische,
sondern kommen ja auch die anderen Aspekte mit rein, mit.
Was ja alle sozialen Netze schon von Anfang an mitgebracht haben,
also die ganze Problematik der Beleidigung und
Bedrohung und dem Bilden von Banden im Netz und dem Hating und all das und das
macht natürlich auch vielen Kids eine Menge Ärger.
Ich würde abschließend nur einen kleinen Hinweis bringen, weil es auch gerade in den Kommentaren war.
Es gibt einen großen Unterschied zu Tabak und Drogen.
Wenn du sagst, du verbietest,
Den Betrieb von beispielsweise Facebook, Instagram, TikTok.
Das ist einfach verboten, in Europa oder in Deutschland bereitzustellen.
Dann wird es das ja auch einfach nicht geben.
Und es kann auch seine süchtig machenden Effekte im Zweifelsfall nicht so gut ausspielen,
wenn es nicht den sozialen Pull-Faktor hat,
dass Leute da rein wollen bei Instagram kann man nochmal anders argumentieren,
weil das halt die Menschen im Zweifelsfall auch zufrieden sind,
wenn sie Amerikaner oder Amerikanerinnen folgen können oder so,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall,
anders als Drogen die ein Individuum süchtig machen durch eine individuelle Wirkung,
glaube ich das ist halt quasi ein Verbot von sozialen Medien,
quasi und zwar von dem Geschäftsmodell.
Das ist das, weil du das machst.
Solange das Geschäftsmodell funktioniert, würden die das ja auch immer wieder anbieten.
Dann funktionieren auch so Sachen wie, es wird umgangen oder so.
Aber ich glaube, dass anders als bei Drogen oder Alkohol, die trotzdem immer
verfügbar gemacht werden,
weil es immer Nachfrage danach gibt, glaube ich, dass dass tatsächlich so ein
breites Verbot von Social Media
über alle Altersgruppen sich sehr viel effektiver zeigen würde als ein,
sagen wir mal, das Verbot von Heroin oder so. Ja.
Weil du dir eben, oder früher Cannabis oder sowas, jetzt darfst du dir deine
Cannabis-Pflanze auf dem Balkon züchten.
Viel Spaß mit deinem selbstgezüchteten sozialen Netzwerk.
Nochmal, ich rede ja ganz besonders nicht davon,
normale, ehrliche Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten wie Fediverse oder sonstiges altersbeschränkt zu machen,
sondern eben dieses Geschäftsmodell gezielt Menschen süchtig zu machen,
das glaube ich, das ist sicherlich schädlich für Kinder, aber genauso schädlich
für Erwachsene aber da war auch einer der Kommentare, der sagte ja, wenn wir,
ein Verbot machen und das demokratisieren also oder quasi demokratisch regeln
dass eben alle gleichermaßen davor geschützt werden von den Kindern, dass man sagt so,
Also die einen sind anfälliger als die anderen und so weiter und das machen
wir durch ein Verbot, klärt man das einfach, vereinheitlicht man das.
Das war auf jeden Fall ein Argument, was ich erstmal interessant fand.
Was bei all dem aber ein bisschen außer Acht gelassen wird, ist,
irgendwie muss dieses Alter ja auch geprüft oder nachgewiesen werden.
Dazu gab es einen Kommentar von Stefan, der sich auf die Diskussion mit Discord
und deren Ankündigung eine solche Altersverifikation einzubauen,
damit man nicht irgendwie auf einmal auf böse Inhalt stößt, wenn man zu jung ist.
Dazu schreibt Stefan, zum Thema Discord und Altersprüfung bzw.
Persona habt ihr das eigentlich Schockierende, den Mechanismus,
der mit jedem Gesichtsscan ausgelöst wird, gar nicht angesprochen.
Und er verlinkt dabei auf einen Artikel, der das nochmal genauer beleuchtet,
beziehungsweise spezifisch eben wie dieser Dienst Persona, der unter anderem
wieder mit Peter Thiel verbunden ist, tatsächlich funktioniert.
Da steht dann unter anderem, sobald ein Nutzer seine Identität mit Persona verifiziert,
führt die Software 269 verschiedene Prüfungen durch und durchsucht das Internet
sowie staatliche Quellen nach möglichen Übereinstimmungen,
etwa indem sie ihr Gesicht mit politisch exponierten Personen abgleicht und
für jede Person Risiko- und Ähnlichkeitswerte berechnet.
IP-Adressen, Browser-Fingerabdrücke, Geräte-Fingerabdrücke, Ausweisnummern,
Telefonnummern, Namen, Gesichter und sogar die Hintergründe von Selfies werden
analysiert und bis zu drei Jahren lang gespeichert, so dieser Artikel.
Außerdem steht da auch noch, dass Discord auch mittlerweile gesagt hat,
dass das ja nur ein Experiment war und dass das jetzt beendet sei.
Ja, es hat dann noch so Suspicious Entity Klassifikationen, also das Ding hat
halt wenig überraschend, die Software, die da verwendet wurde.
Nicht nur gelernt, Alter zu erkennen.
Und das ist, so bitter es klingt,
natürlich auch naheliegend, weil du wärst ja blöd, wenn du irgendwie Unmengen
an Gesichtern und Gesichtserkennung und so weiter anlernst,
Und das als Service anbietest, nicht vielleicht direkt noch andere Biometrie-Scans,
Merkmale und Scores zu machen, weil wenn das jemand ist, der verdächtig ist,
dann wird es ihm ja auch keinen Kredit geben oder so.
Das heißt, hier werden natürlich noch sehr viele andere Scores von so einem
Startup mit errechnet, insbesondere wenn da Peter Thiel investiert ist.
Also die Technologie, die da zum Einsatz kommt,
ist eben, es ist halt nicht Hey Magenta,
es ist halt eine Menschenklassifikationssoftware anhand des Gesichtes.
Das ist dann von Pim-Eis, was wir vor vielen Jahren hier, vielen Jahren,
in mehreren Jahren inzwischen hier besprochen haben, der Gesichtersuchtmaschine und so.
Also das ist halt das Ding ein paar Jahre später. Und das ist schon, nun...
Sehr unangenehm, was da implementiert wird. Man muss sich ja dann jeder sein Gesicht reinhalten.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwie ein Peter Thiel-gefandetes Überwachungs-Startup
ist, gibt es ja nichts Schöneres für dich, als jeden Menschen,
der sich bei irgendeinem blöden Social Network anmelden will,
so einen schönen Gesichtsscan zu machen.
Und man muss sich halt jetzt auch echt mal darüber im Klaren sein,
was Software heutzutage aus so einem Gesichtsscan rauszieht.
Weil diese Argumentation mit, ja, jetzt können wir ja das Alter überprüfen und
so, das klingt schon fast wie ein Vorwand, weil du kannst natürlich alle möglichen
Schlüsse daraus ziehen.
Die müssen nicht zwangsläufig alle richtig sein, aber es wird ja auf jeden Fall versucht.
Also Racial Profiling zum Beispiel ist damit natürlich wunderbar machbar.
Du kennst ja diesen klassischen Witz mit irgendwie Polizeikontrolle und dann
holt der Polizist da so seine Farbkarte raus, so mit verschiedenen Hautfarben und so.
Von weiß okay bis braun schwierig,
und das kann man halt hier vollkommen automatisiert machen, dass das Ganze sich
dann aber auch noch mit staatlichen Datenbanken abklärt und keine Ahnung Terror,
Verhandlungen und was nicht alles damit noch macht oder wie wir das jetzt in
den USA zu erwarten haben wir erkennen jetzt mal hier politische Gegner oder was weiß ich.
Andere Merkmale, die vielleicht auf eine sexuelle Orientierung hinweisen und
dann ziehen wir daraus unsere Schlüsse.
Oder auch nur, wir aktualisieren unsere Datenbanken, die dann für andere Sachen verwendet werden.
Also auf jeden Fall so eine Sache und naja, jetzt ist insofern ganz gut,
dass Discord da zumindest erstmal einen Rückzieher gemacht hat,
was diese Firma Persona betrifft.
Ja, aber was sind ja da, also diese, und vor allem, das ist ja auch nur,
das finde ich ja auch sehr spannend, diese Analysen, sie lesen sich echt super,
das ist halt hauptsächlich irgendwie so,
mal das Frontend analysiert, mal geguckt, was das Ding alles für Werte zurückliefert,
also, oh Mann ey, das ist schon wirklich nicht so schön.
Nun, ja, also das mit der Altersverifikation ist wirklich,
und wir haben ja häufig darauf hingewiesen, auch immer wenn Khaleesi über Chatkontrolle
redet, spricht sie auch dieses Thema an, natürlich auch bei uns.
Das ist die Idee, irgendwelche Altersgrenzen einzuziehen und dann automatisiert dieses Alter zu prüfen.
Da kommt eine Technologie zum Einsatz, die willst du eigentlich nicht ausrollen.
Und das ist auch ein sehr großes Problem, weil eben, nochmal,
das sind nicht nur die Kinder, die da ihren Ausweis zeigen müssen oder ihr Gesicht zeigen müssen.
Und genau dieses Zeig mir dein Gesicht, Ist ja so,
dann sagst du, hey, da muss jeder, jede oder jeder seinen Ausweis zeigen und
dann kommen die KI-Overlords und sagen, nee, nee, gar kein Problem,
lass uns einfach dein Gesicht scannen, wir rechnen einfach 297 Werte und vergleichen
dich und wenn du ein Krimineller bist, dann liefern wir dich direkt,
melden wir dich direkt den Bullen, ne, das ist halt, also, weißt du, das ist so,
Oh, da kommen wirklich eine ganze Menge Überwachungsdinge auf einmal zusammen,
die wir dann halt auch noch in irgendeinem Peter Thiel-gefandelt ein Start-up geben wollen.
Und dann sagt Discord, ja nee, wir machen das nicht mit denen.
Und in drei Wochen ist das dann kalter K-Fan, das ist halt eine andere.
Und nicht nur wir melden das den Bullen, sondern wie wir jetzt schon gesehen haben,
wir melden das dann in Realtime so einer Behörde,
die quasi nicht mehr auf der Basis der Verfassung steht und die einfach dein
Haus raidet und dich irgendwie in den Wagen packt und irgendwo hinfährt.
Elma Guetta ruft die Bullen.
Jetzt haben wir doch eine Anwendung.
Ach ja. Nicht so schön alles. Okay.
Wo bleibt die Freiheit? Wo bleibt die Freiheit, Linus?
Ja, das ist ja, also es gibt eine Webseite, die jetzt aufgefeilt ist,
freedom.gov wo sich offenbar unter einem,
zumindest unter einer Government Domain, also einer US-Government Domain,
so angekündigt wird, ja,
wir verschaffen euch Freiheit,
wenn ihr unter Internetzensur leidet.
Beispielsweise, weil X wegen Verbreitung von,
irgendwelchen Deepfake-Nudes gesperrt wurde oder so oder ein VPN,
wenn hier irgendwie gegen euch vorgegangen wird, weil es ja alles ein Kampf gegen Free Speech,
Ich finde das sehr,
tja, unterhaltsam,
weil natürlich ist, also information
is power, reclaim your human right to free expression, get ready.
Also das ist halt schon.
Tja, also, dass die USA,
Meinungs- und Zensurfreiheit,
als großes Thema sehen und auch gegenüber von mir aus anderen Staaten,
und gegen deren Interessen versuchen durchzusetzen und zu ermöglichen in deren
Rechtsraum, das hat uns halt auch sowas wie Tor oder Signal gebracht.
Weil dass sie das tun, das ist schon eine klassische Tradition,
dass sie für diese Werte eben auch einstehen und technische Methoden zu ihrer
Durchsetzung gegen Angriffe und Unterdrückungen ermöglichen.
Bisher war es halt immer so, dass, naja, okay, das nutzen auch Kriminelle eben
der unschöne, aber tolerierte Nebeneffekt war.
Und was wir bisher nicht hatten, war, dass sie sagen, naja, okay,
das setzen wir eben von mir aus auch gegen, was weiß ich, gegen Europa durch,
wenn die auf einmal unsere Plattformen versuchen zu regulieren oder so. Das ist der neue Teil.
Auf jeden Fall finden wir uns jetzt in einer, ironischerweise,
in einer Situation wieder, in der sich China seit 15, 20, 30 Jahren befindet,
dass eben versucht wird,
den Zugriff auf das, was die USA als Meinungsfreiheit erachtet, auch gegen,
juristische Mittel oder Sperren oder Gesetze oder Regulierungen in Deutschland durchzusetzen.
Ich finde es natürlich absolut ironisch und absolut insane.
Aber es überrascht mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht,
weil ich weiß, dass sie das eben quasi eine grundsätzliche, auch diese Rede,
die der Vance, war das ja letztes Jahr auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
gehalten hat, wo er da meinte so,
ich mache mir Sorgen um die Meinungsfreiheit.
Die Rede war ja natürlich an das Publikum gerichtet, aber sie war natürlich
auch an die Amerikaner und Amerikanerinnen zu Hause gerichtet, die es halt verfolgen.
Und in der US-Öffentlichkeit ist es natürlich, das ist so die eine große wichtige
Sache, die das freie Land von dem unfreien Land unterscheidet,
gibt es da Meinungsfreiheit.
Und natürlich ein komplett falsches oder Redefreiheit, komplett falsches Verständnis
davon, wie das jetzt irgendwie in diesen Fällen alles richtig,
aber der Vorwurf in diesem Land gibt es keine Redefreiheit oder das Flag,
das wirkt halt auch innerhalb der USA sehr stark wenn du sagst so,
achso du kommst aus einem Land, wo man nicht sagen darf, was man möchte.
Genauso wie dieser Ami, der gestern im Zug der durfte auch sagen, was er möchte,
nämlich Excuse me sir, I was gonna sit there und wollte mich von meinem Sitz
verscheuchen auf den ich mich gerade gesetzt hatte und da habe ich halt von
meiner Redefreiheit Gebrauch gemacht und ihm erklärt was eine Reservierung ist.
Aber er durfte das sagen, im Freisland,
ich finde es auf jeden Fall ironisch, mehr als eine Ankündigung gibt es da nicht, aber dieser...
Dieser Blickwinkel aus der US-Regierung wundert mich nicht und der wird auch
innerhalb der USA relativ stark wirken.
Ja, also vor allem, ich meine, wenn jetzt die aktuelle US-Regierung einen VPN-Zugang
anbietet, dann wissen wir ja, was der für eine Qualität hat.
Ja klar, wir haben ja einen VPN von Facebook für euch.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, damals auch behandelt, das ist schon viele Jahre
her, aber Facebook hat ja sogar schon mal einen VPN angeboten.
Die haben mir so einen VPN-Anbieter damals gekauft.
Das war ein VPN, das mehrere Vorteile hatte,
unter anderem, dass sie Bilder nochmal stärker komprimieren,
dass du Daten sparst und das war so ein VPN-Anbieter, den sie gekauft hat.
Und dann hat Facebook halt die User-Daten, also die Traffic-Daten genutzt für
Market Research, um herauszufinden, was machen die Leute eigentlich,
wenn die nicht bei Facebook sind.
Und die Sage will es, dass das naja dazu geführt hat, dass sie also dass es
insbesondere so Erkenntnisse hatten, als es Snapchat und so weiter gab.
Dass sie halt wissen wollten, wie groß und wie mächtig und wie gefährlich ist uns denn Snapchat.
Verstehe.
Aber warum hat denn dein, weil du deine Reservierung nicht richtig durchsetzen
konntest. Ist da irgendwas schiefgegangen bei der Bahn?
Nee, das war einfach nur ein blöder Ami. Der, weißt du, wie Amis so sind, ja.
Der einfach natürlich irgendwie komplett unfreundlich mich anpampt,
dass ich mich gefälligst von dem Sitz verpissen soll, wo er sich hinsetzen will.
Und, ähm, ach ja, Amis halt, also was willst du sagen?
Ich dachte, das hätte da vielleicht eine Schwankung im Buchungssystem bei der Bahn gegeben.
Nee, gab's nicht.
Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen,
Ich kenne auch keinen, der sich über eine Schwankung beim Buchungssystem der
Deutschen Bahn beschwert hat.
Was ist passiert? Es gab DDoS-Angriffe auf das Buchungssystem der Deutschen Bahn.
Also Buchungssystem der Deutschen Bahn, www.bahn.de, Suche oder was,
kannst du ein Ticket kaufen. Viele machen das.
Und da die App, der DB Navigator, die idealerweise hat die Zugang dazu,
speichert das Ticket dann und dann kannst du Bahn fahren.
Und dahinter verbirgt sich natürlich ein IT-System, das irgendwie die Fahrtberechtigungen
verwaltet und verkauft und einträgt und gültige QR-Codes signiert oder was auch immer.
Und...
Dieses System war Ziel eines Denial-of-Service-Angriffes. Computersysteme haben endliche Ressourcen.
Alle Computersysteme haben endliche Ressourcen.
Primär bei so einem Service sind das natürlich die CPU- und RAM-Ressourcen.
Du musst ja die ganze Zeit Tickets verkaufen und hier bezahlen.
Und nee, hast du Namen, Kontonummer falsch eingegeben.
Ach, Stornierung. Nee, kannst du gar nicht mehr stornieren. Das waren Sparpreise.
So und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist also ein vielbeschäftigtes IT-System und für diese Beschäftigung braucht
es CPU und RAM und eine Internetanbindung.
So, die drei Sachen, wenn eines von den drei zu viel beansprucht wird,
dann fängt es an zu ruckeln.
Und wenn man das massiv überanspricht, dann hört es halt unter Umständen auch
vollständig auf, verlässlich zu antworten.
Kann man machen, indem man besonders komplizierte Aufgaben gibt oder so.
Dann würde man vielleicht beim Compute irgendwann mal an die Grenzen stoßen.
Oder wenn man es wirklich schafft, so viel Netzwerktraffic dahin zu schicken,
dass die Leitung saturiert ist.
Und da gab es jetzt halt letzte Woche irgendwie Schluckauf bei der Deutschen
Bahn und dann haben sie gesagt, ja wir sind, haben sich irgendwann auch öffentlich
dazu geäußert, haben gesagt, ja hier, wir sind Ziel eines.
Denial-of-Service-Angriffs und wir bemühen uns den unter Kontrolle zu bringen,
haben den unter Kontrolle zu bringen, haben den unter Kontrolle gebracht und
dann gab es immer mal wieder Schluckauf, so gut.
Und sicherlich, also wenn du einen Denial-of-Service-Angriff bekommst,
dann musst du über Netzwerkmanagement versuchen, dem irgendwie Herr zu werden.
Und wenn du das bei deinen, quasi da, wo deine Leitungen ankommen,
nicht hinkriegst, dann musst du irgendwann vielleicht Hilfe suchen und dir beim
DKICS oder so schon möglichst viel Null ruten lassen oder so.
Du musst halt irgendwie den Traffic möglichst so weit wie möglich weg von dir
schon filtern, wenn es so viel ist.
Oder kurzfristig halt die Ressourcen hochfahren, um mit der Menge zurecht zu kommen.
Das kostet aber Geld und kann nicht dein Interesse sein.
Das ist ein Problem, was alle Webseiten am laufenden Band haben,
die einen mehr, die anderen weniger.
Und entsprechend würde ich davon ausgehen, dass die Deutsche Bahn das im Prinzip
am laufenden Band derartigen Angriffen ausgesetzt ist und auch am laufenden Band,
die in der Regel wahrscheinlich automatisiert wegmanagt Und irgendwie ist es
jetzt einer Gruppe gelungen,
das halt mal entweder durch die Menge oder durch eine Schwierigkeit,
den Traffic zu erkennen als bösartig früh, ist es dann gelungen,
die Ressourcen zu überlasten.
Was Spannende ist ich habe niemanden klagen hören ich kenne niemanden der gesagt
hat ich konnte nicht Bahn fahren oder ich konnte dem scheiß Ami nicht meine
Reservierung zeigen als der böse wurde oder so,
habe ich keine Geschichte von gehört
gab es bestimmt die Frage ist welches Ausmaß die hatten und ob jetzt,
ob dadurch sag ich mal in dem normalen Tag der Bahn ernsthaft mehr Probleme aufgetreten sind,
als an jedem anderen Tag der Bahn.
Und ich würde mir tatsächlich die Frage stellen, war nicht eventuell einfach
nur Ziel der Angreifer, eben in die Tagesschau zu kommen und dass darüber berichtet wird.
Und das fand ich tatsächlich, das hat in einem sehr großen Ausmaß stattgefunden.
Das war Tagesschau-Thema, Bild-Zeitung, überall Cyber-Angriff auf die Deutsche
Bahn, meine Güte. Sind die Kundendaten noch sicher?
Und dann durften sie alle lange Interviews geben, inklusive mir.
Und ich habe dann versucht zu sagen, mehr als dass man da kein Ticket kaufen
kann, passiert halt auch nicht.
Also Denial-of-Service-Angriffe sind ein Ärgernis,
aber sie sind eben auch eines, dass man in den Griff bekommt und in den Griff
zu bekommen hat und auch das ist ja der Bahn auch hier gelungen.
Insofern weiß ich nicht, ob das nicht ein bisschen out of proportion dann war.
Gleichermaßen, natürlich sollte man sich das nicht gefallen lassen.
Natürlich gibt es da einen Urheber hinter diesen Angriffen und man muss sich schon sagen, okay,
da eskaliert jetzt etwas, wollen wir uns vielleicht wehren.
Ja, Jürgen Schmidt, der Ju von Heise, hat so ein bisschen gesagt,
naja, okay, das eskaliert jetzt, wir lassen uns das gefallen,
was ist hier mit unserem Pazifismus und da kann man jetzt von mir aus sagen,
ja, okay, du hast mal jetzt halt irgendwas zurück,
stört dir aber genauso wenig wie uns.
Ich weiß es nicht, ja. Ja.
Es schließt auch damit, die defensive Bemühungen darf man natürlich nicht vernachlässigen
und ja, das passiert halt.
Muss man eben dann mal wegmanagen. Insofern fand ich das ein bisschen übertrieben.
Der einfache Weg für die Deutsche Bahn wäre natürlich gewesen,
ja okay, dann schalten wir den Krempel halt hinter Cloudflare,
aber das passt halt nicht so zur Souveränitätsdebatte gerade.
Was auch nicht so zur Souveränitätsdebatte passte, war,
dass im Heute-Journal in einem Beitrag über die Einsätze von ICE,
also der US-Grenzpolizei, die da regelmäßig mit sehr extrem brutalen Einsätzen
bis hin zu mehreren Tötungen und regelmäßiger starker Gewalt gegen Menschen
immer wieder von sich reden.
Macht, da gab es einen ZDF-Beitrag, wo.
Erstens ein KI-Video gezeigt wurde,
von einer weinenden Mutter und Kinder und das war aber halt nicht echt und dann eine weitere Sequenz,
die zwar nicht gefälscht war, aber wohl irgendwie nichts mit dem Thema zu tun
hatte, also zwei falsche Videos zur Bebilderung der Nachrichten und das ist natürlich auch,
das ist schon wirklich peinlich.
Also das ist, das darf nicht sein. Dann haben sie irgendwie gesagt,
ja, das war ein technischer Fehler bei der Überspielung.
Wir hätten eigentlich die KI-Szene kennzeichnen sollen, wollen,
das ist uns irgendwie nicht gelungen.
Aber ey, komm, ich guck, also ich mein, wenn ich heute Journal gucke,
dann nicht, weil da die KI-Videos gekennzeichnet werden, sondern weil idealerweise,
da keine drin vorkommen.
Ich meine, ich hatte den Beitrag gestattet, da wurde auch drauf eingegangen,
dass es halt KI-Videos gibt zu dem Thema.
Aber das war, nee, nee, das konnte man so nicht machen.
Naja, jetzt haben sie sich natürlich dann nochmal richtig dafür entschuldigt.
Aber das ist schon ein bisschen peinlich.
Handwerkliche Fehler.
Handwerkliche Fehler. Also ich meine, erstens war es so, dass in diesem Video
wohl das Sora, also das ist mit dem Video-Generations-Service von OpenAI erzeugt worden, Sora.
Und naja, es war halt etwas, was irgendwie so getan hat, als würde es irgendwie
vielleicht unter Umständen zu diesem Thema dazugehören.
Und das Ganze aber auch so ein bisschen mit dieser Optik von,
ja das ist hier so auch, das wurde gefilmt,
das wurde gepostet und kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass das auch von irgendjemand gepostet wurde, aber es hätte halt halbwegs erfahrenen
Bildredakteuren schon mal bekannt gemacht worden sein, dass es Sora gibt.
Ich meine, das war ja nun viel in der Diskussion in den letzten Monaten.
Also erstmal rein aus Tech-Perspektive, weil es halt irgendwie krass ist,
aber natürlich auch aus einer journalistischen Perspektive.
Und deswegen hat ja dieses Video dann auch dieses Wasserzeichen.
Das hätte man also auf jeden Fall schon mal erkennen müssen.
Und das andere, dass halt einfach da ein Video kommt, was vielleicht echt ist,
aber halt nichts mit der jeweiligen Situation zu tun hat.
Das kommt noch dazu. Ich meine, wir sind wahrscheinlich auch mittlerweile alle
ein bisschen übersättigt. Das soll jetzt gar nichts entschuldigen.
Also das ist natürlich völlig Banane, was das ZDF gemacht hat.
Und es war auch extrem peinlich, wie sie erst versucht haben,
da ihren Arsch zu retten und solche Ausreden und Erklärungen.
Das Muster zu liefern, anstatt einfach zu sagen, ja, sorry, irgendwie,
dass das passiert, hätte nicht passieren dürfen.
Jetzt wurde da halt diese amerikanische, also in den USA zuarbeitende,
nicht Moderatorin, sondern Autorin dieses.
Beitrags wurde irgendwie geschasst, kam aber später raus, dass eine längere
Version davon schon mal im Mittagsmagazin auch lief.
Da waren dann aber diese Videos nicht dabei.
Also es ist wirklich so ein bisschen unklar und wird bisher einfach noch nicht ausreichend erklärt.
Was da jetzt beim ZDF eigentlich wirklich gelaufen ist und sie haben da irgendwie
auch jetzt nicht das Rückgrat, einfach mal klar Schiff zu machen.
Das ist schon mal grundsätzlich zu bedauern.
Auf so einer Metaebene muss man sagen, Ich meine, mich hatten Bebilderungen
von Fernsehnachrichtenbeiträgen schon immer genervt.
Weil es halt oft so, naja, irgendein Bild muss halt immer zu sehen sein und was nimmt man dann?
Naja, wenn die Arbeitslosenzahlen kommen, dann hast du halt so einen Schwenk
über den Eingang von irgendeinem Arbeitsamt in Deutschland und dann hast du
Cut und dann hast du irgendwie irgendwelche wartenden Personen, die irgendwie,
was weiß ich, in der Warteschlange stehen und Cut und dann eine Tafel mit ein
paar Zahlen. drauf und das war schon immer langweilig.
Und auf YouTube zum Beispiel, wenn du da auch mal guckst, da gibt es ja mittlerweile
auch so viel, also einerseits auch schon so komplett generierten Quatsch in
allen Varianten, das ist wirklich, wird langsam wirklich schwierig.
Der teilweise gar nicht mal mehr versucht irgendwie zu erklären,
dass das hier irgendwie alles AI generiert ist, sondern es ist halt dann aus
den unterschiedlichsten,
Gründen, Meistens hat es natürlich was mit Geldverdienen zu tun,
aber manchmal eben auch einfach mit politischer Motivation werden halt diese
Videos generiert und online gestellt,
aber auch so die normalen Sachen, wo halt irgendwas erzählt wird und wo dann
einfach so vollautomatisiert mit was wird gerade gesagt,
ah, da kommt Auto drin vor, kommt Fabrik drin vor und dann wird halt automatisch
aus so einer Videobild-Datenbank irgendein Clip rausgesucht,
der dann einfach angezeigt wird.
Und dann blickst du die ganze Zeit auf diesen ganzen Bildbrei und weißt schon
irgendwie gar nicht mehr, was Sache ist.
Und ich glaube, da zerbröselt auch langsam allen das Hirn, auch denjenigen,
die irgendwie sowas machen.
Und wenn jetzt der öffentliche Rundfunk und Nachrichtensendung im Allgemeinen
ihren hohen Anspruch, von dem sie ja selbst behaupten, dass sie den hätten,
wenn sie den aufrechterhalten wollen, dann müssen sie sich an der Stelle einfach
mal deutlich unterscheiden.
Und das tut man eben nicht durch solche Sachen.
Ja, du hattest gerade so ein bisschen, also das war nicht irgendwie eine amerikanische
Journalistin, sondern das war die Auslandskorrespondentin,
die das New Yorker Büro des Senders leitet, also das ZDF leitet,
war vorher in Beijing und als Korrespondentin in Beijing und als Studieleiterin in Tel Aviv.
Aber sie sagen halt, naja, okay, das sind so schwerwiegende Verstöße gegen Richtlinien
und journalistische Standards, dass wir sie jetzt abberufen.
Und ich weiß nicht genau, wie heutzutage die Schnittsysteme für Beiträge beim ZDF aussehen.
Und ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie da ein Video rein gerät und wie man das schneidet und so weiter.
Ja, aber die haben, solche Redaktionen haben häufig sehr fürchterliche Systeme,
wenn ich das mal so sagen darf,
mit so einer, wo es dann Quellen und Videos gibt und so und.
Das darf einfach nicht passieren, es stimmt, aber ich kann mir auch,
es ist jetzt halt, der Workflow war halt sicherlich nicht,
dass die gute Redakteurin sich das irgendwie von YouTube runtergeladen und zurechtgeschnitten
hat, wie wir uns das ungefähr vorstellen, wie wir so einen Beitrag schneiden würden.
Da kann ich mir auch in der Abfolge Fehler vorstellen,
trotzdem, das darf nicht passieren, dafür haben wir genug für den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk.
Ja, es ist ein tragischer Fall, es war auch irgendwie klar, dass es irgendwann
mal jemandem passieren muss.
Ja.
Jetzt ist es passiert.
Jetzt ist es passiert. Jetzt haben wir das auch hinter uns. Das ist auch gut.
Das muss ja irgendwann passieren.
Dann würde ich noch gerne davon erzählen, ich war, wo war das denn?
Montag, genau. Am Montag war ich bei der Weltpremiere von Fun Facts.
Und das ist ein wirklich interessantes neues Projekt, wo sich wirklich Unmengen an Comedians.
Und Redakteurinnen, Factchecker, JournalistInnen zusammentun,
um ein unterhaltsames Nachrichtenformat zu machen.
Live auf Bühnen in Berlin, München, Köln, Hamburg, Leipzig auch noch.
Und das sind ein tägliches Nachrichtenformat machen.
Und das eben Fun Facts, das sind Fakten, das ist noch trotzdem Spaß.
Die erste Sendung, die erste Folge wird am 2.
März mit Luisa Neubauer, Anne Brorhilka und Marc-Uwe Kling sein.
Dann zweite ist mit Sarah Brosetti und Daniela Seperi und dann geht das so weiter.
Es sind Unmengen an Leuten.
Nico Semsroth, Sebastian 23 und wen du nicht alles kennst.
Ralf Rute. Wirklich ein sehr, sehr, sehr breites Ding.
Und die zeichnen glaube ich viermal, also an vier Wochentagen auf und senden an fünf.
Quasi an einem Tag wird dann noch quasi so ein etwas längerer Teil für einen
Freitag aufgezeichnet und das könnte echt ziemlich cool sein.
Das Ganze mit Heinz Strunk, 6.
April Heinz Strunk in Hamburg, da kaufe ich jetzt ein Ticket,
mach mal Pause, da will ich hin.
Okay, also es ist richtig viel, richtig coole Leute. Ähm,
Ja, und das finde ich ganz cool,
zumal sie, also natürlich auch diese Veröffentlichung muss irgendwie auf die
Plattform natürlich setzen,
werden aber auch alle Videos primär selbst hosten und über föderierte soziale
Medien verbreiten und so. Das könnte echt interessant sein.
Das finanziert sich primär durch Spenden und Tickets.
Insofern könnt ihr mal anschauen, wenn da eure Stars dabei sind,
dann könnt ihr euch Tickets kaufen.
Aber das findet jetzt nur an Location statt und nicht im Internet.
In Theatern dann quasi.
Ja, aber kommt es dann auch irgendwie, wird es da aufgezeichnet und später dann auch da.
Ja, genau. Und dann, das hatte ich gerade, deswegen habe ich gesagt,
dass es über Plattformen und soziale Medien primär in den föderierten sozialen
Medien verbreitet wird.
Ach so, aber die sind doch jetzt verboten, habe ich gehört. Wie kommen wir denn da jetzt ran?
Ja, nur für die unter 16.
Guck mal gerade, welche Aufzeichnung ich noch besonders empfehlen würde.
Am 29.
Oh ne, Quatsch, Entschuldigung, das ist falsch. Ich sag dann nochmal Bescheid, welche ich empfehle.
Vielleicht die vom 29. April. Oder?
Das hängt doch mal alles ganz von der Stadt ab.
Na, natürlich in Berlin.
Du willst doch zu Heinz Strunk, der ist ja nicht in Berlin.
Ich geh auf jeden Fall zu Heinz Strunk, das ist in Hamburg. Ja,
da geh ich dann hin, das empfehle ich nicht. Da will ich ja Ticket,
da gibt's noch Tickets, die will ich ja haben.
Tja, das musst du jetzt, bevor ich die Sendung raushaue, musst du das dann geklickt haben.
Das muss ich auf jeden Fall. Ich würde jetzt echt gerne eine spezifische Sendung
von den Fun Facts empfehlen.
Egal jetzt. Die Leute wissen doch selber.
Was sie mögen. Dir ist das vielleicht egal.
Hängt doch nicht von deiner Empfehlung ab.
Vielleicht gibt es da einen besonderen Gast, den die Leute kennen,
du Pillemann. So, dann geht es weiter mit was anderem.
Wenn das alles egal ist. die Beschlagnahme des Adetnauers in Sachsen auf der Autobahn war natürlich,
Die Polizei hat die Richterin angerufen und hat gesagt, ob sie bitte die Beschlagnahme
anordnen kann. Da hat sie gesagt, nein, kann ich nicht.
Ich kann das nicht aus der Ferne beurteilen.
Das könnte er vor Ort entscheiden und dann könnte er auf jeden Fall nicht.
Kurzer Hinweis für neue Hörer von Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Wir haben natürlich nicht hier
den Kadaver des alten Bundeskanzlers beschlagnahmt gesehen, sondern Bus.
Also wenn man das erklären muss, dann bin ich enttäuscht.
Linus, unter Umständen sind jetzt gerade Leute.
Die haben gerade zugeschaltet.
Ja, die sind gerade über die Altersgrenze.
Helma Genta, mach mal nächsten Sender auf meinem FM-Radio.
Die sind gerade über die Podcast-Altersgrenze rübergekommen.
Achso, die dürfen jetzt erst.
Sie mussten mit allem rechnen. Es werden auch am laufenden Meter neue Revolutionäre,
nachgeboren, die einfach dann irgendwann diesen Moment haben und sich denken
so, ach, das für alte weiße Männer hier.
Das ist halt gar nicht so scheiße, was die erzählen Ja.
Dann verlenken wir nochmal die Adenauer Sendung und also am Sonntag ist wieder Ditt,
Denn es wird mal wieder ein Monatswechsel stattfinden. Und damit ist der Sonntag, 1.
März, ist der Digital Independence Day.
Und auf der Termineseite, die wir auch verlinken, da steht jetzt 421 bevorstehende Veranstaltungen.
Und ärgerlicherweise sieht man da direkt eine Gruppe, die ihre Veranstaltung
offenbar zweimal angelegt hat.
Das ist natürlich peinlich, weil dann sind es ja nur 420 aktuell und wir müssen
nochmal an der Usability von dieser Termineseite arbeiten.
Aber da gibt es jetzt wirklich eine ganze Menge Events und eine ganze Menge
Dinge und da wird sich auch noch einiges tun.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin echt sehr erfreut, wie viel da passiert und wie viel
da entstanden ist, wie viele Organisationen da Events anbieten.
Events ist einfach immer, ja, wir treffen uns, wir gucken mal zusammen.
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Das sieht man dann, was sie machen.
Möckern Kiez e.V. macht dann irgendwie die Linux-Install-Partys in Hamburg,
im CCHH ist dann irgendwie Thema, Messenger und so.
Das ist alles relativ divers und man kann sich alles anschauen.
Ich bin echt, da muss ich wirklich sagen, das hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass ich da so eine unglaublich breite Community ergeben würde und das macht
mir sehr, sehr viel Freude.
Alright, ich würde sagen, damit ist dann aber auch diese Sendung vollständig.
Ja, Helma Genta, Outro.
Oder ne, ein Witz zum Ende. Wir müssen noch einen Witz zum Ende machen.
Wie ein Witz zum Ende?
Machen wir keine Witze? Ne, ist ja Funfacts. Es gibt ja jetzt Funfacts.
Jetzt können wir endlich ernst werden hier.
Ne, zum Ende der Sendung sind alle Witze auserzählt. Dann gibt es dann noch ein schönes Outro.
Das hören sich alle natürlich bis zum Schluss an, weil es so schön ist.
Und dann stellt sich diese wunderbare diese wunderbare Befriedigung ein. Die man einfach stört.
Dieses Du-Du-Du-Du, wenn man aufgelegt hat.
Ja, wenn man so eine Sendung zu Ende gehört hat, dann geht es einem gut.
Insofern wünschen wir euch noch einen schönen Nachmittag oder Abend.
Ciao, ciao.
Bis dann. Tschüss.